America is desperately looking for a
leader now don't get me wrong I'm not
telling DeSantis to go on a podcast on
smoke weed to win some people that are
going to vote for him I'm not telling
you that he's not going to be doing that
but the fact that this guy's got the
audacity to go out there and do things
like that he's showing I can help solve
a lot not only Florida's problems
because people track record-wise give me
one Governor's resume FYI did you just
see what just happened let me just give
you guys a stat here does anybody know
who just broke the record for the most
money ever raised by a governor in the
history of America it's a guy named
Santa so he just broke the record for
the most money ever raised by a governor
in the history of America his name is
Ron DeSantis how does that happen people
from other states are supporting this
guy they ain't even in here people from
other states so if a guy is going to
take a risk like that and for you taking
risks because quite frankly too many
people on all the other sides are
playing it way too safe I want a real
leader today